during the boom of climate investing
there's a surprising industry that's
expected to rake in the green it's
garbage North America's biggest landfill
operator which manages your waste is
known as WM it's best known for
collecting trash and putting it in a
landfill if you've lived in America and
you've thrown something away chances are
they have handled your trash but
beginning in 2026 the company says
sustainability focused Ventures will
reach 15% of its total profit or about
$740 million a year here's how the
company plans to profit from government
tax credits and a market that's hungry
for renewable energy and recycled
materials this is the economics of
WM over the next four years WM plans to
invest 1.2 billion dollars into making
fuel from riding garbage when the trash
that ends up in a landfill decomposes it
releases a slew of gases one of them is
methane known commercially as natural
gas which is more environmentally
harmful to the at atmosphere than carbon
dioxide landfill owners would previously
capture methane and burn it off to
prevent it from seeping into the
atmosphere now they collect the gases
and nearby plants separate the methane
which is piped into power plants for
electricity or into homes for heating
and cooking WM already operates 66
landfill gas plants all over the country
landfill gas is much more expensive to
produce than gas drilled by energy
companies but thanks to federal tax
breaks and other incentives to reduce
pollution landfill gas has become
economic viable for producers and buyers
WM expects to receive $250 million in
tax credits installing gas works at 18
of its landfills thanks to last year's
climate tax and Healthcare Bill the
climate Bill really was a bit more of a
catalyst to do it faster waste
management is pursuing these projects
because they're immensely profitable
right now and it's made projects at
smaller landfills which will be less
productive than large landfills it's
brought them into the money they're now
economical WM says this expansion will
allow it to produce eight times more gas
than it does now and will generate $500
million in additional profit through
2026 not counting the tax breaks
currently natural gas from landfills
only accounts for less than 1% of the US
natural gas supply but because of the
growing demand the number of renewable
natural gas projects including landfills
has nearly doubled in the past 5 years
and production has significantly
increased wm's competitors are also
cashing in with their own landfill gas
plants Republic Services is planning to
open a total of 77 renewable energy
projects and reported that about 88% of
its landfills are covered in biogas
collection systems but WM is not just
investing in landfills the waste
management company is making large
investments in upgrading its recycling
plants like this one outside of
Cleveland our 100,000 ft facility is
built to manage 12,000 tons a month of
recycling these Investments are helping
plants to increase recycling recovery
rates and the company expects the new
tech to add $240 million to its bottom
line over the next 4 years the WM
Cleveland facility prior was a
commercial recycling plant so we could
not offer single stream commercial
recycling this investment now has opened
up our capacity to both residential and
Commercial recycling we're able to
provide single stream recycling for them
one of wm's upgrades involves automating
its recycling plants with Optical
sorters powered by AI so behind me is
one of 12 Optical scanners within our
process system the optical scanners are
made to pick 900 to 1,000 picks per
minute through programming and imaging
it identifies a specific product and
there's an air jet that then identifies
that product onto a conveyor over to the
bailer to be bailed for the unuser it
makes the Sorting go a lot faster it
removes Human air and what they found is
it it really boosts not only the
quantity of the what they call recovered
materials but they're getting a better
quality it's cleaner it's not a jumble
of other stuff in there so they're
spending a lot of money to automate
these recycling facilities in order to
boost efficiency where we have made
these Investments we're lowering our
operating costs by reducing some of the
labor intensity of the business all that
stuff goes to these facilities where
it's sorted into different materials you
know mixed paper corrugated cardboard
clear bottles that all gets separated
that's a very intense labor not a very
pleasant job these companies have a
really hard time keeping people in those
jobs and these Optical sorters have
already begun to increase Revenue
recyclables have become an increasingly
valuable commodity themselves as more
companies promise to use recycled
packaging there's a big shortage of the
materials of recycled material that
companies like cocacola or Amazon or
whoever uses a lot of plastic and paper
can reuse for new packaging so the race
is on to really get that stuff out of
the waist stream and companies are
willing to pay up for those materials
even though they're more expensive
because they've told their investors and
their customers they're going to clean
up their act Plus plus more cleanly
sorted recyclables fetch a higher price
WM says the optical sorters are able to
increase Blended commodity value by
about 15% per ton and the company
expects that it will be able to recover
25% more reusable materials by 2025 and
we're continuously looking at that
algorithm to make sure that we capture
more material long term and
sustainability Investments are even
going back to one of wm's core
businesses
collections
people need to do the job right at the
start and we have a technology that we
use called smart truck that helps us
with that smart trucks come equipped
with cameras when the truck tips
recyclables into its Hopper its Tech
captures footage of the materials for a
team of technicians to review these
technicians scan for any objects that
can't be recycled and monitor the amount
of
recyclables if WM detects misplaced
recyclables or overflowing bins it sends
a not notification to its commercial and
residential customers informing them of
the issue in our regions where we have
that smart truck technology we've seen
residue reduce roughly 20% in those
markets so that's key let's just say a
really dirty pizza box mixed in with
paper you know that good paper or good
cardboard gets contaminated and then it
can't be recycled much of this
technology is already in place today we
definitely think about out the materials
that are in our landfills as just that
materials they're a resource what we
think of as trash a lot of it is really
some of the hottest Commodities of the
green
[Music]
economy